To absolutely no one’s surprise or at least to
non-die-hard MCU fans, The Marvels is flat-out
bad. Your enjoyment will obviously vary off of
purely how much fun you have with the movie and
how much of the humor lands for you personally.
Because at the end of the day, that sort of thing
is extremely subjective. But for this review,
I’m going to primarily be analyzing the quality
of the character work, plot, and overall writing
and why I think it’s a failure. Because to me,
those are the most important aspects that make
me fundamentally care about a film. Some jokes
and a happy tone with a fast pace won’t make
me automatically love a movie and I can see
why people can enjoy this significantly
more than something like Secret Invasion.
So the biggest and most flawed aspect to me
was the character work. Out of the collection
of characters within the movie between Carol
Danvers, Monica Rambeau, Kamala Khan, Nick Fury,
and the villain, there was only one character that
actually felt well executed which was Kamala Khan.
Iman Vellani breathes so much energy and charisma
into Kamala that she’s always an extremely
endearing and lovable character. Her bubbly and
fan-girly persona gives the character so much life
to the point that the contrast between Monica and
Carol feels massive. Although that kind of dynamic
between these characters is pretty likable because
of the sheer difference in energy and personality.
However, I think this also exposes how much
of a charisma sink both Carol and Monica are
as characters or even actors. Carol, I would say
is a bit more likable here than in her own movie
and she’s showing some personality, but she still
comes across as being pretty bland. And the same
thing applies for Monica. They’re supposed to be
the more grounded and serious characters, however,
the movie doesn’t offer enough depth for them to
really become interesting. For Kamala, you care
so much about her because she’s still a kid and
there are stakes for her well-being because her
family cares about her. Along with her vibrant and
unique perspective of absolutely loving becoming
a superhero with her literal hero growing up. It
energizes her with a significant likability that
Monica and Carol come nowhere close to. Because
the only thing those two characters have is a
minor past conflict in that Carol never came back
to help raise Monica. So since that development
is awkwardly dealt with and is basically breezed
over within a few minutes of it being brought up,
there’s really nothing the movie does to make
you care about these two other main characters.
That’s why I think Kamala absolutely carries the
film. Without going into spoilers, there’s this
past action that Carol did that has come back to
haunt her, but the movie doesn’t really dive into
that and is only dealt with at surface level. The
writers could have done a lot more internally and
emotionally to make Carol Danvers a significantly
more relatable character. Like she may be this
unstoppable god-like figure, but these major
choices she makes have consequences and she has
to personally deal with the heavy guilt associated
with that. However, the movie essentially briefly
brushes over this and doesn’t do much with that to
make Carol a more interesting character. So to me,
1 of the 3 leads was enjoyable while the other
2 came across as being bland and mostly dull.
From here it gets significantly worse because the
handling of Nick Fury and the villain were truly
horrendous. Nick Fury is literally delegated as
a comedic relief character as 95% of his screen
time is just making quips and jokes. This is
obviously very jarring especially coming off
of Secret Invasion in which Nick Fury is supposed
to have his groove back and I assume be at least
kind of serious, but nope, that’s not the case
at all. Every single moment he’s used to rattle
off jokes and to be honest some of them landed
because I love Samuel L Jackson, but the entire
time it was happening I couldn’t help but think
the writers were ruining the character. He’s
slowly being corrupted for short-term comedic
value as this brutally serious character turns
into a fluffy teddy bear. There’s really not much
else done with his character as he kind of just
meanders around in a background subplot. Which
I’ll get into in a minute. Then finally we have
the villain. Now Marvel is extremely inconsistent
with their villain quality where they could either
make complete masterpieces like Loki or Thanos, or
they could make atrocities. And the villain who I
don’t even remember her name which is honestly
really sad. Apparently, her name is Dar-Benn,
is sadly in the atrocity tier. It didn’t even feel
like the writers tried to make her a compelling
villain. She’s just a bland, comically bad person
who has a motivation that is so devoid of logic
that I don’t think it really constitutes as a
spoiler so I’ll go into it. For this segment,
I’m going to talk about the villain’s motivation
which is that Carol Danvers does an action that
negatively impacts a planet, and now the sun is
dying. I don’t remember exactly why that is the
case since it was explained pretty quickly or if
it even was at all. But the first major thing that
wouldn’t make sense about this is that: if your
sun is dying, then your planet’s temperature would
plummet. Thus destroying the population. Because
the movie visually shows this sun as being almost
extinguished and if that was the case, I’m
sure the planet would be uninhabitable. And
also without an atmosphere, I think in the
beginning of the movie. So to me at least,
the entire motivation surrounding the villain
is nonsensical because it doesn’t make sense.
So that paired with a villain that has
barely any screen time, is monotonous,
and the creators gave her like 1 minute of
backstory makes her one of the weakest villains
in the MCU. Every character besides Kamala feels
deeply flawed or doesn’t have enough happening
internally to make them intriguing. Which to me
is by far the biggest failure in that by having
an uninteresting main character and villain it
makes the story completely unengaging. Both the
driving force of the film and the overall conflict
doesn’t captivate the audience. So the only thing
that does is the humor and fun tone. And even
though Kamala is a clear standout because of this,
I think the creators realized that and
relentlessly used her high energy in almost
every moment of the film to the point that it
kind of burned me out. Which I still like her,
but she can’t always be dialed up to 11. There
needs to be some kind of balance for the character
and at times they do find that balance while in
others she can feel overutilized. So ironically
this movie feels more centered around Kamala
even though Carol Danvers is the main character.
Moving away from the characters, let’s address
the main selling point of the movie which is the
quantum entanglement. Now all the science fiction
exposition is rattled off so quickly to the point
that I don’t expect they cared if the audience
really understood it. Which is fine to a degree,
because with a vague scientific statement that
sounds half accurate, I can buy this as being real
within the universe. However, what immediately
drives me crazy is if said mechanic is extremely
inconsistent in how it works. So in essence, if
one of these three characters use their power,
they switch places with someone else. I assume
it’s random and there’s not a link between certain
characters. Now the inconsistency arrives in the
fact that in almost every single scene, one of
our characters uses their powers and doesn’t
trade places with another character. They’ll
simply be using it to fight someone casually
as if there’s no entanglement happening, which
is an utter contradiction. This happens pretty
regularly in different fight scenes. At one point
during a training montage, they establish that if
they keep using their power in a sustained sense
after teleporting then they won’t immediately do
it again. It was explained very fast and I wish
I could rewatch it. But they constantly stop using
their power and then use it again. Or they’ll just
be using their power and no teleportation happens.
So overall this leads to a completely inconsistent
usage of the teleporting mechanic to the point
that it just feels like the creators are doing
it whenever they feel like it. This aspect was
really driving me crazy and since this mechanic
was kind of a mystery for the characters, they
couldn’t actually explain it. So you just have to
roll with it and accept how it’s used in the movie
despite it being confusing and contradictory. This
leads into another major flaw in that it makes
some of the action scenes jarring. Specifically,
the ending scene in which all 3 characters
are attacking the villain simultaneously
with their powers. It becomes really hard to
follow the action because the scene both has
really fast-paced editing with quick cuts, has
the teleporting mechanic randomly kicking in,
and 4 characters all fighting at once. The action
because of this quickly becomes overwhelming and
thus is why I think it’s pretty jarring. There
is one action scene towards the beginning of the
movie in which the 3 main characters are in
different locations as they fight 3 separate
battles. That was more digestible since each
set piece had a single hero fighting at a time,
but again, the teleporting mechanic quickly
became erratic in how it was used. So the big
issue here is that this was one of the major
selling points of the movie and I think it was
handled pretty poorly. Even though I did
partially enjoy that first action scene.
Now going into the plot of the movie, there are
certain parts about it that I want to address.
Firstly, this isn’t really a spoiler but there
is a portion of this movie that is dedicated to
the skrulls. Given that Secret Invasion sets up
there being peace talks with the Kree. Now the
first thing that is immediately contradicting
is that there are skrull outposts on different
planets. I thought the entire conundrum in Secret
Invasion was that they couldn’t find any habitable
planet which is stupid in of itself, and they had
to go to earth. Which is inherently a contrivance
to instill a false sense of conflict on earth.
However, here, through an utter contradiction, the
Skrulls are living on other planets albeit to a
small degree I guess. So this entire dynamic with
the Skrulls is confusing because of this, along
with us not knowing these specific Skrulls so the
politics between them and the Kree just led me to
not care. I’d assume a character like G’iah would
be greatly involved with this kind of conflict
considering that she’s just a more OP version of
Captain Marvel, but I doubt the writers would even
consider that. So this entire chunk of the movie
felt very underdeveloped and the Skrulls then
evaporate out of the movie. The only redeeming
aspect about this sequence is that it introduces
a character flaw for Carol in that her actions
can have negative consequences and she isn’t this
almighty being who can only do good. Even though,
as I said before, I don’t think the writers
explore that angle of her character enough. Then
before going into the main plot, there are two set
pieces that will primarily be talked about a lot.
One of them is a planet in which the only language
people speak is singing. Although they’re singing
in English, but they don’t understand English
if it’s not in song format. So yeahhh. So to
put simply, this feels like the writers were high
and were trying to come up with a quirky gimmick
for a planet and it didn’t land for me at all.
Then for the second, it’s tied directly to Nick
Fury’s subplot which feels largely pointless and
I can’t really talk about it in detail because
it spoils the ending of it. But talking about
it vaguely, it was so crazy and unhinged from a
writing perspective that I just ironically found
it funny. It’s going to be polarizing because of
how ridiculous the scene is, but I just lost
it. Especially at the music they used for the
scene. So I hate to admit it, I kind of enjoyed
that scene the most, even though it was batshit
insane and I kind of respect the writers for doing
something that was that unhinged. It made me laugh
but at the expense of breaking reality. But yeah,
the main plot for the movie is very stereotypical
and plays it safe. The heroes essentially come
together through the first half of the movie and
then they simply overcome the main conflict. At
no point is there any clever writing or story/plot
subversions and it is mostly a by-the-numbers
Marvel movie. Except it has a much faster pace
which is both a blessing and kind of curse in
that we at least got out of the movie faster and
they also couldn’t take a lot of time to build
characters. Like Carol desperately needed some
more character development and I would have been
fine if they slowed down more for that. There are
definitely more minor aspects about the story that
are poorly written but I think I went through the
biggest issues being the badly written characters,
the quantum entanglement mechanic being confusing
and inconsistent, and the plot being mediocre
with a plethora of dumb writing beats. So I can
see why Marvel fans can have a fun time with
this movie, but anyone who is on the fence or
isn’t loving the MCU anymore clearly won’t enjoy
this movie. Unlike Guardians of the Galaxy 3 which
was pretty much universally loved by everyone.
I’ll be trying to review Loki season 2 as soon
as possible and I actually enjoy that show. I
don’t purely hate the MCU and I wish it can be
better. Thank you for watching and let me know in
the comments what you thought about The Marvels.